[Music]
tonight President Trump unveiled his
fake news Awards here with reaction the
host of michelle malkin investigates on
CR t v-- michelle malkin and the hills
joe concha I loved every one of it
never mind the stories they don't cover
and this is the tip of the spear the tip
of the iceberg Michelle it is it's it's
simply brilliant I've got to hand it to
President Trump and to everyone who
compiled this list I think that the
execution leading up to the revelation
of these awards was also brilliant
because look at what you had you had all
of these thumb suckers in the media
working themselves up into an
olympic-sized lather I counted about a
half dozen pieces just over the last 24
hours
decrying the fake news awards before
they were even given as some sort of
escalation and a threat of violence
against press freedoms and of course we
had Jeff snowflake or corn flake flake
flake on Senate floor right frosty flake
embarrassing himself with his hyperbolic
speech comparing our president in a very
fun way being able to tell truths about
the fake media comparing our president
to Stalin these people as you have so
deftly pointed out over the last hours
and days and months have completely lost
their minds and now President Trump is
going to force them to cover each and
every single item on the list everybody
in in the bubble the echo chamber you
know all they are I mean we know who we
could name them we do name them but this
is why it's so important they've been
saying that this is so bad for freedom
of the press
we know what's bad for freedom of the
press lying and and doing and and not
only lying the those choices they won't
cover the biggest stories that exist in
our lifetime because of their agenda and
they still can't get over that they were
wrong on the election or Sean you can
make the argument that Donald Trump is
exercising his First Amendment right by
pushing back at the media as he did
during these things
he has one well apparently presidents
have never really done that before right
Republicans are always so worried
they're gonna get bad press so they kind
of cow town and didn't really punch back
like this I would argue that Trump
supporters probably see the media as the
opposition party more than Pelosi or
Booker or Warren or anybody in the
Democratic why shouldn't he push back
this is well-deserved Awards for losers
well if you see the list here really is
a great microcosm of 2017 quick rundown
of it
CNN won won four awards and I would
imagine they'll make an ad campaign out
of that I'm not being sarcastic they'll
see it as a badge of honor and that's
fine by the way that's really twisted
because they were wrong in every count
right exactly I don't think they'll like
montage of the of the [ __ ] this
whole network
well it's your whole fake news now I
believe they said it 165 times I want to
say it here but I can't show well if I
say they have to sit in a meeting and
getting lectured that I shouldn't have
said it and followed policy and I don't
feel like sitting through that meeting
I'll let you Michele jump back in again
New York Times one - Washington Post -
ABC one Newsweek one here's interested
here's the interesting part
BuzzFeed they released the dossier was
not nominated very interesting also
unscathed never said didn't get an award
NBC surprising CBS and Fox News shocking
well maybe all right you know what's
happening I think if you look at this
statistics which showed last night 2017
the year they tried to destroy a
president with media research but it's
also a year that they created the
biggest disservice to the American
people they are hurt when they can't get
the truth Michele yeah that's right and
just to add an footnote to Joe's tally
the New York Times I think would I would
actually add one more since of course
Eric Lichtblau
came from the New York Times to CNN to
commit the same kind of media
malpractice that he did at the New York
Times the fish wrap of record look to
the point that you made Sean - about why
shouldn't our president push back
against the media I would turn that back
- against all of those Republican
senator sellouts over the last couple of
days who've been auditioning for John
with the liberal media do they not
remember the pushback under the Bush the
Obama administration and I'm not just
talking about all the spying that the
Obama administration did on journalists
from cheryl atkinson to the Associated
Press to Fox News remember that the
Obama White House had specifically
assigned the White House communications
director at the time Anita Dunn to go
out everyday in press briefings and
specifically attack Fox News and what do
these people want to do they want to
disarm our president and his supporters
and grassroots conservatives and
independents who put him in office and
gag him from using his own first
dimensions to push back when the media
is wrong ever be the person they want
him to be
he's never gonna put plane loads of cash
cargo plane loads of cash and give them
to Iranian mullahs and kiss their ass
and try and bribe them not to be
murdering dictators to want to destroy
us Joe saying ask them have you sit in
the meeting tomorrow then I'm not going
to the meeting okay good for you look
and when people say well maybe things
will change in 2018 we've clearly seen
that this year has actually been worse
than last year only 16 days in what
happened with Sanjay Gupta is it
incredible to me because he does a
diagnosis from afar that's one thing he
is also a neurosurgeon okay so think of
him as the electrician and Ronnie
Jackson wasn't the only person that was
involved in the cardiovascular part of
president Trump's prognosis he also was
actually consulting with cardiovascular
surgeons from the Cleveland Clinic which
which is one the leading hospitals in
the country and those are the plumbers
right so you have an electrician talking
about what a plumber should be doing
right and it's kind of like when I go to
get my colonoscopy next month thank you
well my dad had I got to go every four
years I would call my podiatrist I mean
that's the thing you don't want to say
this on CNN the whole network that's a
very that's a very graphic thing there
people on the west coast I could enjoy
the dinner right now so so thanks for
that roll traffic you know the president
has a great sense of humor and they'll
never enjoy it I thought this was great
tonight good this year